it's a feeling natural thing for I think
for most indigenous peoples to to care
about their footprint and the way that
we engage with deep al the environment
and how we respect that we did pray
that's pretty close to zero waste values
growing up but I didn't even think of it
that way
until the beginning of this year when I
decided that I'll try this thing zero
waste for one month and I thought it's
y'all share this with others so I called
it hashtag the month of June that's
really focused on it being one month
like maybe one month I'll try this thing
out and and then I really struggled for
about I mean I I think I probably failed
immediately because as it turns out you
can't really decide to go zero waste you
have to undo so much of what you've
learned I've discovered how much we
believe that we need stuff that we
actually don't need so I had to undo a
whole lot of beliefs and a whole lot of
practices and one of those things was
discovering that I didn't need cleaning
products I don't buy cleaning products
at all anymore just don't need them and
I was trying things like baking breed
and making biscuits and because I didn't
I'm a total sugar freak and I didn't
want to be buying chocolate like I
normally would find either a source of
where we can find plastic or package
free produce or grow it so it's tricky
focus for me like it's really is trying
to keep the rubbish bin empty this is
some of the paraphernalia that I've
collected for zero waste over this year
I don't have all of us with me all of
the time and I'll have usually two or
three of these things depending on what
I think I'm going to need during the day
and if I strike something that I would
like to buy but don't have the ability
to to buy without having something like
this no don't buy it we're not winning
every day but we're trying every day and
that's what I say to people who are
interested in this journey is try every
day do what you can in a bit more every
single day and at the end of the month
there was no question of whether I will
keep going and a lot of it was to do
with the joy that I found and practicing
this lifestyle you reconnect with the
earth you
can it back to what the earth provides
for us how hard it tries to sustain us
and how lucky we are that we have a
planet that is despite our great efforts
is still trying to keep us alive